We the People of the United States in
order to form a more perfect next to the
Declaration of Independence the
Constitution is the most important
document in US history and affects each
of us every single day but today many of
us are unaware of how and why our
freedom depends on it
Hillsdale College America's uniquely
independent classical liberal arts
college is offering a free online course
Constitution 101 for a limited time you
actually have to study some very
fundamental things to learn the meaning
of America and the causes of its
Constitution without the Constitution
and without a knowledge of the
Constitution we don't know what our
liberties are how they're secured or how
to perpetuate them with over a half a
million already enrolled Constitution
101 is available free for a limited time
it's gonna make you feel different about
being a citizen in the United States so
register today online or by calling the
number on your screen right now pursue
truth defend Liberty don't wait register
Friel's Dale colleges free online course
today